[Music]
what about sunday's fashion arrivals Amy
Adams is desperate for a dress she was
showing shoulder last night and today at
her Globes Finn that should be a fun
Friday plenty of last minute ladies will
keep us guessing I have a fitting in a
few days yeah did you have your dress
for Sunday are you ready I'm just about
ready totally different this year I
might be naked as for host Jimmy Fallon
he suited up and ready any secrets and
things we should look forward to put in
the opening music Olga this is musical
guests in the opening it's fun I think
we'll have more music in the show than
we've ever had before as for who'll
secure those coveted statuettes I've
worked really really hard to get here
it's ryan vs ryan in one big acting
category if gosling edges out reynolds
it could help lala land make history
it's the frontrunner to potentially win
seven Globes no other film has ever done
that it's very very exciting and nominee
Meryl Streep already a winner I am so
blessed the most nominated star will
take home the cecil b demille award
fingers crossed for Street to sweep her
category too for a record-breaking ninth
win give my speech right now
[Music]
you